[音楽]
ん
ヒューム
[音楽]
多分
恋店の通り
はい毎号がはい
千本ありますよねっ
いやまず前からデラックスケルトうんやろうって話をしていて本当に8カ月ぶりんがあ
絶対しないと思ったでも本当にまさか
バカでしょだってそう
鮭で甘いも性もあるんですけど本当には歌だった路線もあるから本当に絶対見たかって
なってると思ったらねちょっと
アノテーション動画の説明欄とかここらへんに
うまい棒1000本買う動画なれっ
歩け俺たちならこの巨大料理作る
ラック助っ人ための世界俺で行
7 us エアウェイズおむつれ恋は相撲あげないくいますかはい行きますか
いきましょう
それゆえねーません人や下
まだで邪気でねつべこべ言わずねー
くればいいんですよこれはい
何でしょ
て早速食べていきましょう本当にでわーっ
ねえあんただけ押しますかそうですねそうですね吉田屋
バーン
はじまりますねこれ前半後半に僕はけると思っ入ってくださいはい
ん
あああああああああああ
ましょうを探せ
ございました
ええええええ
uh
can you do
dee
菜園と10本あんな大阪たよあとやあとこれを100杯すればあいつらやってるん
あとは90分
ええええええ
[音楽]
n
家康くんはどうなります
はん
ここん
me
ん
ええええええ
t 4
ああああああああ
ちょっといいじゃダメってよ
ワーンっ
[音楽]
全然 us 分僕のがいるまあ女が強い
大前は余裕やろん
ええええええ
re
トゥデイ
ん
ね
[音楽]
ちょっともう
とりあえずれ限界じゃないんですよます
全然嫌いじゃないけどあと身の危険をそうだろ
買って不明だよん
助っ人を呼びますん
wh
ええええええ
[音楽]
寂しい
wh
me